- Alright we've reached that moment,
where I share some magic
from the inter webs.
This is what I'm liking.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
When some dude named
Chad says, "hold my beer"
it's usually not a good sign.
Not the case though.
At a party in New Jersey a few weeks ago,
when party goers spotted a
baby deer had fallen in the
water. This particular, Chad,
didn't hesitate to jump
in and check this out.
- Oh my god, it's gonna die.
- What if he doesn't get it?
(crowd chatter)
- I'm not going to let them die here.
- Go get him, go get him.
- Here, I'll take that.
- Where's he going to get out?
It's a baby deer.
- Oh my god.
(water splashes)
- This is awesome.
(crowd chattering)
(laughing)
- He's out,
look he got him!
(crowd cheers)
- Alright, that video was seen on TikTok,
over 7 million times.
Chad is clearly a hero
to all woodland creatures
and he's dialed in now watching
on our partner station,
NBC for New York. So Chad,
what made you jump in?
(crowd applause)
- Thank you.
So Kelly,
I was actually at a party down
in Tom's River and my wife
ran over to me and told me
that there was a baby deer that
was drowning in the lagoon.
So that's when I took to myself
and ran over to that dock,
took that shirt off, got
that money out of my pocket,
made sure my phone wasn't in my pocket
and went right at it and had to just get
across that water, save that baby deer.
- Oh, it's so cute.
(crowd cheers)
- But the best part is what happens next.
So tell us.
- So we had went on,
made a couple phone calls to
try and find someone to help us
with this deer. Cause we
didn't know what to do with it.
It was 4th of July weekend.
Nobody was answering.
We wound up actually taking
it upon ourselves to go on
Google maps,
found an actual small patch of
woods that was near where I'd
got the deer.
And me and my wife went on a
little venture in our truck and
sure enough,
the baby deer's mother was
standing there waiting for us
right at the tennis courts over there.
We got out of the car.
And if you look in the back of this video,
actually you'll see the mother
deer standing back in that
greenhouse.
You can see her right back there
and they went off together.
- What?
That's so crazy.
You're like a male Snow White right now.
I love it. Chad.
It's so amazing. Thank you so
much for sharing that video.
It made all of us very happy.
I'm liking your posts right now.
(bell dings)
- That is so awesome.
- No, well that's not all,
our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, my man.
So they will be using their
G2 gelling pen to write you a
check for a thousand
dollars. How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Yeah!